hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to within deep sorrows now
this game has been in development for
quite some time on game told I've been
waiting for it for a few months now it
came out yesterday and from what I've
seen so far it looks like there's a lot
of work put into this game so I'm eager
to give it a try in 1994 a demonic
presence had entered a different
dimension dreams
Johnston Barker had suffered from this
monstrous demon best drinking within him
he had no choice but to face his fears
and to seek throughout his nightmares
his conscience guy is conscious guided
him searching for a particular object
that was personal to him and him only in
Barker's case oh my goodness well you
guys read the rest of that I didn't know
how much time I had five school fine
well then we're kicking off the crazy
rifle ticket I didn't catch a word of
that Oh what is going on now the bed is
leaking goobie got me glowy thingies
what is going on oh he wants me to go to
sleep huh that doesn't seem like a good
idea I gotta say this one that I was
really impressed with how it looked from
the trailer and green shot someone died
this might actually have some good stuff
to it oh look I'm dreaming
19:58 st. williams school I can't move
okay
why oh there I go
oh listen this delightful seems like the
edge of the world falls off right then
and there the guessing it wants me to go
in the school can I run I don't think
though I can jump with the control
button now that is weird
oh okay perfectly normal
alright go in the school why not
with my control jump button maybe
another button is sprint I don't know I
saw you up there I saw that figure in
the window over there you can't fool me
my name's mark Barton I'm super duper
smart hello no yes no maybe so
I can't go in there so how about round
the side there anything in the trash can
no some kind of invisible wall pushing
me away from there okay invisible wall
there too well what do you want me to do
maybe it's clicked interact you other
buttons base diff caps-lock hab Guerra
that's wrong I don't know what it wants
me to do what's that sound you guys hear
that
ah here we go here's something baby
maybe not maybe I'm just mistaken odd I
heard something there like a thumbies
bump tribal war drums something of the
like what is that
come sir that trash can where am I going
am i going into the woods why am I going
into the woods what is that over there
Jimmy about a paperclip that's gotta be
good right can I pick a lock with a
paper clip I'm guessing that's the only
reason that I got that okay all right I
like it so far
definitely got the atmosphere to it I'm
actually excited I haven't come across
the pretty decently made indie horror
game in a long time
graphics are nice this is made on the
Unreal development kit so it's got some
powerful tools behind it let's go inside
oh I get to pick it myself oh and let me
just jam it around yep got it I'm good
I'm good expert lock big right there
master need so I'm still in the dream
world and I need to go in and do
something
pardon I walked into the school and I
fell on my side
here we go
well let's see what's going on I don't
have a flashlight er that what was that
I saw press e Y oh oh I get it I pressed
the use button for the light switch also
known as the light switch there are no
use buttons in real life okay so why am
I in this school can I get the bar alarm
there light switch yeah okay I got
batteries the light full oh yeah Oh got
a flashlight good ha ha I have light
hello Alfred Van Buren what's that sound
yeah why not a good idea that that
heater is leaking or whatever I don't
know oh that's how it's gonna be
I'll I like it like what is with this
this is unnatural darkness here oh I see
oh uh excuse me no no oh is that me
breathing a better about me breathing
all right the light switches I can
actually use here it seems to be very uh
spotty power throughout the building
here I'm still not sure what the main
threat of this game is even if there is
one and I like that there's not sure if
I'd like but there seems to be a wall of
darkness that just kind of limits my
visibility what does this mean
into the box I don't want to go into the
box you go into the box use me pardon me
do you want to run that by me one more
time can't go in here can't go through
here what the hell I jump over it no
okay that might be the other side of the
area where I was before anything in
there that I need what is that some sort
of scritchy scratchy on the wall of that
locker there other than that I seem to
just be going the wrong way
so let's just keep walking over this way
I'm smiling because I'm actually
interested in what's going on as opposed
to most of the indie horror games that
you find around these days what Oh what
hang on what my flashlight doesn't seem
to be pointed in the right direction I
saw something in there sorry I can't
play make it out
scratches on the chalkboard a that must
have been murderous to hear nothing else
in here though right
alright our just tell what's important
what's not nothing seems to have a glow
about it which is pretty decent I mean
he's have too many clues gotta leave
something to exploration Oh something I
just spit all over my screen but I don't
care what's going on hey wait a minute
isn't this the front door that I came in
wouldn't that have led me to here in the
first place
why did I wake up in a classroom I got
to remember that I am actually dreaming
so none of this may be real all this may
not be real is probably what I should
have said but I don't have time for
grammar oh okay
so abnormally slow opening doors huh
who's that
Dali whoa a sack bear oh I don't know
what weird world you come from but
that's not a sack bear oh I'm pretty
sure in what strange world would that be
a sack barrow
anything important here anything
like Oh Johnston Barker little kid what
about wait wait a minute what about
Johnston Parker was there a series of
numbers that I needed how do I get back
to that what what what I do I didn't do
anything
all right then so Johnston Barker what
am I gonna do about all this I can't
jump over this oh well maybe I can I
thought I know I can but there's an
invisible wall though it's no point
anyway so I have a sack barrow that I
need to use on something to get
something out of the way I'm guessing I
can probably use it again okay or not
gimme was that actually something it was
that just to think ambience ambience
you can't run a few movies just did the
same slog I was going before I need to
find something that I can move out of
the way I'm assuming that the downed
cabinets over on the other side by the
thing with that book oh it's got a Chloe
where I'm supposed to use it how
convenient
I love this this is fantastic it does a
lot of build up I haven't even seen a
threat yet that's important give me some
time to get to the whoa what the ha
excuse me what am I doing here what am i
doing exactly you want to run that by me
one more time what the hell ha ha ha ha
what am i doing what am i doing ok I
guess I'm getting things and I'm moving
them over here it's just a little wonky
on that department what the hell ha ha
I'm more amused than perturbed by the
stove alright then
I'm just moving things one at a time
because I'm a big win
all right there we go one last thing and
then I can go I guess with my sac Baro
of mine and follow you there something's
gonna happen isn't it okay here you see
me I heard some can't tell me I didn't
because I know I did
heard though I heard some what no no no
oh you're kidding me we're talking about
those are the in ERISA oh god oh no oh
no oh no oh
Alexander Vandross all right so I've
gotten to the area of the school where
things are boarded up and I wanna go I
don't wanna go to here I probably wasn't
supposed to go this way first but
something told me that the room filled
with red lights is gonna be bad you guys
probably wanted me to go down that way
first but I'm just gonna do a bit of it
all right I'll leave well that was that
something just sugar sugar all over that
door handle all right let's see what's
up in the hallway of death up there
this looks good bring it on
of course it's in the bathrooms oh I
gotta go in the ladies restroom really
all right let's go in oh I thought I was
gonna go in my flashlight went in all
right never mind then maybe I'm not
supposed to go it's the only one that
wasn't boarded up what was I supposed to
think
go there oh oh I see I'm guessing I
can't go through there no how do I turn
that off what we do wait did I go the
correct way and I just didn't let me do
anything
confused I'm hearing all sorts of
strange noises but nothing's happening
what am I supposed to do
hello anything here no no really
why not my sac bear oh I could actually
move stuff out of the way tell me your
secrets I guess I could get like at a
crowbar or something to try to rip stuff
off of the doors but oh this is a dead
end - where am I going
what am i doing by doing anything have I
missed something I must've missed
something on the way here he's got oh
there we go a Jemmy bar whatever that
means
I'm guessing that's a crowbar what kind
of crazy messed-up place distance they
call it Jemmy bars when they're crow
bars so there must be some place that I
can rip it off of the doors it go in I
need to go in the length of the
maintenance room to turn off the gas so
it doesn't burn here No
how about over here that's just open
that just opened to be perfectly honest
that would have been very easy to miss I
hadn't seen that beforehand it would
have been e what that door wasn't open
that door wasn't open before that door
was very closed and boarded up we trying
to tell me all right so maybe I gotta go
in the boys bathroom or like that
aha here we go does the freaking arrow
on the wall pointing me in this
directive oh oh good because the
bathroom in horror games is always a
great place to be
who's in there no why is someone writing
it but there is no escape
okay oh that way okay me great I died
what I died
what hey yoki me what the hell happened
Oh can't do that to me ah I saw
something I didn't get a good look at it
mostly because I shut my eyes what was
it you guys tell me what that was
because I don't know I knew something
was gonna happen but what the hell is up
with that uh uh can I just pick the
losing bathroom stall
uh-oh it's fun let's never do that again
I also got that almost blew my eardrums
out those loudest but what is that what
is that no no I saw something
oh oh that OHS that okay all right okay
all right so anyway this game is just
getting a bit too long for this part I'm
gonna have to pick this up in the next
one so this is Hey
okay by the way thank you all so much
for watching click in basis for more
videos that I've done there's always I
will see you in the next video
IIIi don't even know